do we do it there yes we
do so so what I'm wanting to do is today
for you to go home and not just forget
it on your Tuesday class or whatever
night you have your class I want you
to I want you to have it so that you're
never going to let the tiger back in the
cage you know it's out there
it's not being a bully it's expelling co
and you'll then go well it feels really
powerful looking at him R but I don't
actually feel it so you won't feel Coke
you you won't feel your own
power it's
difficult you will feel your strength
cuz when you go like that and you have
to push a bit
extra you'll feel your strength but if
you keep doing it long enough you'll
Coke you this mon
yeah comes
out and then you see you go on we'll say
to what me and Ronnie were talking about
you go on to
this key power or power that you can't
see and that's what you saw in the O
ensi when he was very old they used to
he used to sort of like call them up and
and they'd be falling back down before
they could get on their feet and they
and people go why is they why are they
rolling about and it's cuz
obviously and I hopefully don't want to
get nearer to death just yet but uh but
I think the near closer we get to death
I think martial artists especially their
Aura builds naturally if they've been on
the right path so then that's what I
believe I've sense had so I'd like to
talk a little bit
more about this
technique
shagi
kod so now we've got uh
inwards and
outwards inwards and
outwards we've got this cat ofage where
we we break the thumb Gap here right so
this one I
attack the thumb and break out and my
hand
blade is flat
flat but that can be
sticky right but the more you do that
the more it will come
out what I showed you just before the
teab bre was the inward one
but it mustn't come in as
in but the circle is in where the other
one is
out okay so I want you to do them both
out
in
in Dow
grades give you a little bit more more
but take it Q gra take it if you get
it there this thumbnail those who throw
a rim and Aggy we add this little this
piece this thumbs goes down we add that
in a rim and
Aggie I'm now going to
go a little press it is that's got a
little
press so I've got to again be a magician
quick with my
hands if you want to do the whole coat
guys do the whole coat of
go mustn't come into
you always a away always a
way I've told you so many different
things over the years about all these
points
okay
guys go
go okay so when you got so you got a so
wi and a right so you got an in and an
out okay done